Battlefield losses mounting and a
Ukrainian counter-offensive advancing
Russian President Vladimir Putin says
now is the time to mobilize more troops
to protect our motherland its
sovereignty and territorial Integrity to
ensure the security of our nation and
people in the liberated areas I consider
it necessary to call for a partial
mobilization in Russia
the defense minister says as many as 300
000 Russian reservists will report for
Duty immediately but more could be
called up if necessary Putin also
confirmed that he would push ahead with
a referendum in four regions of Ukraine
including the donbass the referendum
will ask one question do you want to
join the Russian Federation that
referendum often a precursor to full
annexation of territory could happen as
early as this week President Vladimir
zielinski urged allies to focus on what
is important for Ukraine
more support for the Armed Forces for
intelligent services for the special
operations and security service for the
National Guard police and the Border
guards for everyone who is gradually
restoring our territorial Integrity
Western allies have said they will not
recognize a russian-led referendum or
annexation of Ukrainian territories
calling it illegal some analysts call a
referendum a predetermined sham and a
desperate Ploy by Putin there is no free
media to to talk about the issue there
is no election observers there is no
fair counting etc etc even without
talking about all illegality of the
thing because it's a down in violation
of Ukrainian and international law but
in his speech Putin left little doubt he
is ready to escalate this war
Russia has a variety of weapons of
Destruction some more modern than those
in NATO countries
and if our territorial Integrity is
threatened we will use all the means at
our disposal to protect Russia and our
people this is not a bluff
it's unclear if moving more troops to
the front lines and annexing Ukrainian
territory will be enough to turn the
tide in an operation that hasn't gone
according to Putin's plan what is clear
is this war is changing and potentially
entering a new even more dangerous phase
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera Kiev